どうもドクター始めたみんな知育菓子を
知っているだろうか有名なのにねるねる
ねるねありますけどもただお菓子を食べる
のではなく作る過程を楽しんででそれが
子供たちにとっては勉強になったりすると
いう意味で知育菓子というものが存在する
がその中でも特に行かれた野郎それが
こちらのグミ釣れた試しに1個作ってみ
ましょう
[音楽]
容器作ってくれまずは三角カップ取ります
お水準備したこの丸の内側の全部で水
入れるよ
こっちのトレーに三角カップ1杯分の水を
入れて
合わせ酢の素を入れるよすごい普通に泡に
なるんやなぁこれで完成ってまじ次に
ストローを曲げて
沈めると
沈めてますよストローが沈んでるところに
グミの素をかけます
めっちゃ出てくるやんゆっくりと
持ち上げると
[音楽]
すげー
グミがつり上がった
泡につけて食べると
[音楽]
まぁそんなグミ釣れたわ100個用意し
ました
今のを見て皆さんお分かりいただけました
でしょうかこれただの知育合宿ではなく
グミが釣れるんですよストローでそれも
ビヨーンてつけてビヨーンてなったやつを
つけて食べるこれがグミ釣れたというやつ
で上手い人によってはかなり大きなグミが
釣れるらしいんですけども上限が決まって
います内容量が決まってるんですグミ連れ
てはだったら
ジュースの元の袋を100倍泡ソースの
ものも100倍グミの素も100倍にすれ
ば世界最大級のカジキマグロ級のグミが
釣れるんじゃないかということでドクター
初めこの100個のグミ釣れたを使って
世界最大に大きいグミを釣ってみたいと
思います
何からしようかなとりあえず全部開封し
ますね
というわけで100個は決まりました
かなり開封しましたもうドクター始めは腕
が痛いです次にやらなければいけないこと
は準備ですこの容器の内側の線まで水を
ためるのを100回やります
終わりました
でもちゃんと正確に測らないと割合が
おかしくなっちゃってしっかりしたグミが
釣れなくなるのでここは正確に言っていい
ところかと思います次次はこの中に
ジュースの素を入れてフォークでよく混ぜ
ますこれがジュースの素100個分ですね
これをこの中に入れていきます
いきます
ラストです
ジュースの素を100個入れ終わりました
ここがグミ釣れたのを池となる部分なので
この池が大きければ大きいほど巨大なグミ
が釣れるということです続いては三角
カップ1杯の水と
泡ソースの素を混ぜるので三角カップ
100杯の水と合わさるのもと100個を
よく入れて混ぜます
よしやっぱ終わりましたということで
100杯分準備できたのでこの中に泡
ソースのもと100個入れてきます
よし100袋入れ終わりましたこれ混ぜる
とすごい泡になる気がする混ぜます
ガソリンの匂いがする
すごい泡ができましたこれ釣れたグミを
入れる場所なのでかなり大きめにしてやり
ます
素晴らしい
濃厚な泡が完成しました
次ですいよいよグミの素ですねストローを
さしてここに粉をかけてなるのでしっかり
と100個分まずは入れていきたいと思い
ますただこれ気になるのが34回分入って
ます」って書いてあるんですよだからこれ
100個分入れると300円400回分に
なるので全部ぶっ込まなくていいような気
もしますけども全部ぶっこみます
[音楽]
はいこれでグミのもと100袋入れ終わり
ましたすげーこんなにグミのことあること
ないですよ普通
でした確認取れましたというわけで早速
ここからグミ
釣っていこうと思いますここからが本番
です
[音楽]
ここからでしたようやく準備ができました
ここにグミを釣るための巨大な池そして
100個分のグミの元そして味付けする
ためのソースが100個分カジキマグロを
する最強の環境が整いましたというわけで
早速世界最大級のグミ釣っていこうと思い
ますこのちっちゃいストローをこん中に
入れてこうやって釣るんですけども小さい
タピオカストローを2つ連結させたもの
作りましたあと
釣り針をタピオカストローに
ぶっていきました
はいどうでしょう
完璧に平衡取りましたこの最強のルアーを
持ってして史上最強のグミ釣っていきたい
と思いますでは行こう
[音楽]
まだその池にキャスト
します
[音楽]
調整します
[拍手]
なるべく奥までやらないとやばいんだよ
じゃああとは
グミの元をぶっかけます
どんぐらいいや俺は逃げないぜ最強のグミ
をするんだ全部行きます
よ
[音楽]
めっちゃ重いやばいもう
やばいマジで
普通に
釣り竿のしなり方がグミのしなり方じゃ
ねえぞこれちょっと待ってこれ大丈夫か
やばい
[音楽]
というわけで結果やっぱりグミ釣れたって
いう知育菓子がきっとこのサイズ感にあっ
て作られてたものなんだと思います100
個分でやるとちょっと重さに耐えきれなく
てつり上がらなかったですねでも見て
ください皆さんこれつり上がってたらマジ
で世界記録でしたよ
竿が本当に魚釣りみたいになってたんです
よ相当重くなってたんだと思います
マジで魚が解体された後みたいになって
ますけどもやばいやばいやばいやばい
やばいやばい
史上最強にグロいいただきます
[音楽]
見た目がやばいこれあの目瞑って食べたら
本当に美味しい普通のグミ釣れたですこの
量はちょっと一人じゃ食べれないなぁ